Well,
the advice I'd give and if you were my
patient I'd be a little different cause
we'd have a little more time,
but if I can distill it down to the
essence of what we do and of course of
therapy,
the person with panic,
I can say this from the inside out,
since you're looking at a panic
disordered person in recovery,
uh,
has adopted a posture with regard to the
world with the end in which they're on
anxiety is their enemy and they think
that if they can just get the anxiety to
go down,
go away,
not occur as much or not accrual with
such an intensity or at least not occur
here or there and that situation,
that then things would be better.
In fact,
all of that is not the solution to the
problem.
It is the problem holding anxiety is
your own enemy and that it has to go
down,
diminish it,
go away and not happen.
Here is a kind of self invalidating,
interiorly focused process that would
get you even more entangled with these
processes.
Instead,
what we're going to need to learn to do
is to allow your history to bring into
the present thoughts and feelings and
memories and just sort of hold them
mindfully and compassionately and then
focus on what you do and bring them
along for that journey.
So you know,
uh,
feelings or only your history being
occasion by the present moment.
If that's your enemy,
then your history is your enemy.
If sensations or enemy,
your body's your enemy.
If memories your enemy,
you better have a way of controlling
your mind in such a way that you never
are reminded of things that are painful
from the past.
Well,
there is no such thing like that.
That's healthy.
And most of the things that people do
that are called psychopathology are the
unhealthy things people do when they try
to accomplish that agenda.
If you avoid people,
avoid having your buttons pushed,
avoid going to places that might
occasion anxiety.
If you're hammering down drugs and
alcohol.
These are all methods of trying to
amount that unhealthy agenda.
So I would say,
could we instead take this anxiety to be
something that may be of importance?
May even be meaningful.
And it says something about your history
and could we learned to sort of hold it
in a way that's more compassionate,
to sort of bring the frightened part of
view close and treat it with some
dignity and keep focused instead of
making that go go away focused instead
on what kind of life you want to live
connected to,
what kind of meaning and purpose that's
going to be quicker,
more self compassionate and more certain
journey forward than this kind of out
with anxiety in with the relaxation,
you know,
out with the self doubt in the
confidence kind of,
uh,
let's just snap out of it.
Kind of a harsh and,
and,
uh,
lack of,
non-compassionate that place that we
stand with ourselves inside.
Things like panic disorder.
Yeah.